hey here's something fascinating going
on with the Donald Trump uh taxes and
charitable giving scandal back in
mid-september the co-founder of linked
in reed hoffman announced the major
fundraising campaign where he put in
five million dollars he pledged five
million dollars of his own money which
would be donated to veterans charities
if Donald Trump released his tax returns
that five million was then used to crowd
fund and more than another million
dollars has been crowd funded so now
with over 10,000 pledges and read
Hoffman's five million bucks we are at
over six million dollars available to
veterans groups if Donald Trump releases
his taxes the money will be divided up
among ten veterans groups the cost of
Donald Trump well the financial costs
would be zero the political cost to
releasing his taxes seems like it would
be pretty big from everything that we're
learning the pat tillman foundation the
hire heroes us a charity team rubicon
the yellow ribbon fund just some of the
ten charities that would benefit here
and the donors who pledge money are told
and it says very clearly on the crowd
pack crown for crowdfunding website you
will only be charged if Trump releases
his taxes every president since Nixon
has released their tax returns we need
to see Trump's tax returns I don't know
if we will here's again as a reminder
some of what we suspect could be could
be revealed by Donald Trump's taxes
first on the list that Donald Trump as
Russian ties that are much more
extensive than what we believe now or
what it would has been admitted anyway
number two that Donald Trump is being
audited and again that's a bogus reason
that's the reason Trump says he's not
releasing the tax returns but we know
that that's not really a reason not to
number three that he didn't pay any
taxes we have much reason to believe
that that is true after the New York
Times or x release number for that Trump
has ties to the mob number five that he
donates no were very little money to
charity and number six that he is not as
rich as he says he is uh I have to tell
you Pat with every passing day I
more convinced that at least some if not
all of the possibilities on this list
are true yet could be all of the above
and what I love is how this kind of
turned on its head the Trumper that the
offer the Trump made to Obama right that
if he released his birth certificate
from would offer five or fifty million
dollars to charity yet and ultimately
Trump didn't do you do we know why Trump
didn't donate the money that was it
because he said the birth certificate is
not legit I actually don't remember why
he ended up not donating he gave a
deadline for it oh okay so trust Obama
released the birth certificate but maybe
didn't meet the the the completely
artificial an arbitrary deadline that
Trump establish uh it must be really
really bad if at this point Donald Trump
is not releasing his tax returns this is
taking a political toll there is no
doubt about it a majority of those
polled want to see the tax returns every
little bit of data we get like the 1995
tax return obtained by the New York
Times suggests that the suspicions about
Trump's taxes are absolutely true how
bad could it really be we might never
know at this point 30-something days
before the election Trump hasn't
released them so far I can't imagine
that he will gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s